yeah I play whatever you want now no
we're gonna do I don't know this is my
hot pink guitar hey guys I'm Ryan right
by the way I'm Lauren God by the way and
we're gonna do some freestyle shout outs
for you guys she thinks this is
ridiculous that she's never seen any of
the videos that we did of it so we're
you know we're gonna do this and I'm not
gonna lie not gonna say what it took
something a little out of it right now
okay here we go now I also have a plank
it's harder a long time that's why I
think I'm like no you don't believe that
next person to shout out it's gonna be a
man named Jordan Crawford he said please
can I have a shout out
thank you the smiley face thank you oh
thank you yeah all right you ready
okay
these are our travelers Jordan Crawford
he's being earlybird he wakes up and I
come up with a new verse with all these
words Jordan you're the new man you
wanna shout out God say please oh geez I
can't believe you actually said please
don't one ever asks with that question
before
oh man you open the door to these
thoughts I cannot ignore its like
folklore when I think about you Jordan
they you're gonna be with an Asian in
you're gonna start scoring with Lauren
now
nataly's being naughty to your course
have you one too okay if I can also the
guitar and sing at the same time I'm
really cool I'm having trouble with my G
chord
Jordan likes to watch our Channel
Thank You Jordan that smelled with and a
Jordan thanks for watching our channel
to it I don't know it up rhymes with
channel I wished I was wearing a flannel
shirt and I wish that I couldn't think
of anything else besides flannel or
panel or man so listen up
Marcus Greene he said y'all are awesome
can I get a shout out it's time to do
this Marcus green
you got it
how many freedoms tell me like yeah I
got it okay
his name be Marcus green he comes up to
the silver screen he looks upon it he's
leering and here he comes he's gonna
start smirking he looks at the YouTube
channel he looks at her Hollywood panel
he wants to see us put on her joke and
he wants to see himself choke on his own
throat when he's thinking about all the
times and I finally gave him a shout-out
he's been waiting quite a while it's
been a few [ __ ] weeks but hey I guess
I'm on a winning streak with getting
late to the shoutouts well how about
this shout out I say Marcus green don't
be mean you can probably get a body that
is lean we see you and sometimes I see
me and I think about how Marcus is never
full of hocus-pocus he folks up and he's
focusing I guess I'm done with you
Marcus
you run with Spartacus rhymes with
Spartacus and nothing else
Lauren's really good at rhyming but
thank you Marcus for getting me to sing
this song because I'm trying a little
bit is so fun Kanaya
China one two three four five nya one
two three four five he said brother can
I get a shout-out
he's just graduated college man got a
job as doing big things at City Hall so
please if you get this give a brother a
shout-out well buddy one's gonna rap for
you and I'm gonna sing for you
apparently Laurens gonna rap for you
this is not like I'm sorry that your
shout outs gonna suck but I'm just gonna
say that right now if I also knew how to
say your name I feel like that would be
really helpful a little bit I don't know
how to say that good luck Lauren this is
just gonna be like me really laughing
one two three four five
sing for him that singing forget hyah
Oh 1 2 3 4 5
just graduated because he's smart
I hope yeah one two three four five
it's watching my channel because it's
art but thanks for subscribing and now
I'm still singing and I don't know why
because I can obviously not think of
words that rhyme with anything alright
we we have to finish your song okay nya
as a vagina
maybe I wanna be inside of her
maybe it's a boy maybe your guy cuz he
says legs a brother
and Brian is perv
all of his videos are about sex and sex
jokes even though they're not funny so
Lauren's gonna take over actually I'm
just stop the recording freestyle anthem